este miércoles colombia se unió a la
lista de países latinoamericanos que ya
están vacunando lo hizo tras recibir el
lunes 50.000 dosis de la vacuna a facer
que si el retraso las vacunas han sido
recibidas con entusiasmo hoy empieza un
nuevo capítulo en lo que es la derrota
de esta pandemia también fue el primer
día de vacunación del salvador
y el próximo país de la región será
venezuela que anunció que empezará a
inocular el jueves con la vacuna rusa
sputnik b de la que han obtenido 10
millones de dosis sin embargo la
situación de estos países está lejos de
aquellos que encabezan la inoculación
argentina recibió un nuevo lote de 580
mil dosis de kobe shield la vacuna
elaborada por el instituto serum de
india con la fórmula de astrazéneca y la
universidad de oxford de esta forma ya
cuentan con 1,8 millones de dosis y
entraron en la fase 2 comenzando a
vacunar a mayores de 70 años nosotros
estimamos que en agosto septiembre
tenemos vacunado
a todos los argentinos que tienen
condiciones de ser valorado una segunda
fase que se consolida en méjico que con
cerca de un millón de inoculado se está
priorizando las zonas más remotas del
país sin embargo méxico reclamó ante el
consejo de seguridad de la onu una mayor
solidaridad por eso para acelerar
[Música]
y reducir el acaparamiento evidente que
estamos enfrentando por encima se
encuentra chile que ya se sitúa cerca de
los 2,4 millones de inoculados y
registra la mejor tasa de vacunación per
cápita de américa latina'